and for british zimmerman as we
mentioned going to be a second start
second consecutive start against the red
sox
pitch well
only one walk that walk did score gave
up one home run that was jd martinez
gets the evening off at least initially
here's vazquez zimmerman from the belt
here it comes got him
well there's your
the illusion that it's a strike and it's
such a quality pitch it goes right out
of the strike zone it's up two down
devers hitting 182 with one home run he
had that the other day
here in baltimore and no doubter
and there's a line shot for a base hit
into center field herduko rounding
coming in hard and the throw is not
going to get him and the red sox grab a
one-nothing lead
and raffy hit that one on the button
one-nothing boston yes he did another
breaking ball right in his eyes
he stayed right on it
a lot of bad pitches on o2 counts and he
makes him pay line drive
i thought they had a shot at verdugo at
the plate but not even close
xander bogarts up to second evers at
first
marwin was one for three drove in a run
walked a couple of times on thursday
go back into first base and they've got
him in a rundown
rafael devers bogarts is rounding third
he is trying to score and he's gonna
score
and deborah's still in a rundown tag now
but the red sox got that second run
well that looked like the inning was
over
the red sox wind up squeezing out
another run on the base path horrible
base running meanwhile you get a run red
sox starter garrett richardson one era
27.
here's trey mancini he swings and drives
one deep right center field hernandez
back goodbye
trey mancini attacks on the first pitch
and oriole park at camden yards is going
bananas
on mancini's first home run of the year
it comes in front of the home faithful
that ball was shot out of a cannon as it
clears the wall in right center field
almost 112 miles an hour off the bat
my heavens here's anthony santander
that's hit well
way back
it's gone back to back jacks mancini and
santander
and the orioles have tied it to two
mancini first santander follows with his
second deep fly of the year and just
like that the orioles have tied the ball
game up at two
freddie galvez
trying to get going at the plate for the
orioles he's hitless in his last 13 at
bats
three and two one away we'll see if ruiz
is on the move here
richard setz ruiz goes pitch in the
waist swing at a missed strike three
throw down his second and denver's
caught the ball in front of the bag and
he thought that that was the third out
if he applies the tag on rio ruiz
then the inning is over
instead he caught it in front of the bag
thinking that that was the third out of
the inning which it was not and richards
trying to get out of the second inning
without a run
and a little bounding ball two hopper
out to second arroyo sets him down
and the side is retired
and marwyn gonzalez will be next
who's gonna drop down a bunt
and franco will stick in his back pocket
it'll be a base hit for marwin gonzalez
he bumps his way on
the one-note arroyo that's a base hit to
left field and it's going to go in the
corner rounding second is gonzales it's
picked up in left field by dj store
they're going to wave in gonzalez here's
the relay play at the plate and he is
out at the plate
a great relay from stort
all the way to cisco with the tag at
home and the site is retired and the
score remains 2-2 nicely done by the
orioles defense
one out man at first two to the score
hernandez digs in right side the pitch
there's his swing and a high fly deep
center field mullins back at the track
at the wall makes the catch
right in front of the fence he reached
his glove up
and took it
he was right at the base of the wall
he paused he put his glove up
he didn't jump
if mullins doesn't make that catch that
one that actually may not have hit off
the top of the wall that might have just
barely snuck over the fence either way
it would have been extra bases
lines it mocked
knocked down by galvez and
rio says i got you from here red sox
down terrific play rafael devers
one for two in rbi single tonight
this is swinging a high fly ball deep
right field way way way back she's gone
rafi aldebar is his second home run in
baltimore in the series
and he's put the sox in front three to
two i mean all it takes is one
he makes you pay doesn't he
so cedric mullins from the left side
will face hernandez here and the pitch
grounded base hit down the right field
line mullins flying around first base
he'll be picked up by verdugo and he'll
make it into second base with a slide
it's a one out double
for cedric mullins
and that's the time run out there at
second base well alex cora goes to the
bullpen again brings down the
right-hander adam avino be his third
appearance of the season
santander has belted a home run he's
lined to left and grounded to third
[Applause]
high chop
arroyo got him
side retired
good work by adevino they're 3-2 boston
oh for three for ryan mott castle
tonight a couple of strikeouts
there's a base hit ripped into left
field
gonzalez up with it and a lead off base
hit for ryan mount castle
so there's your tying run here in the
eighth comes set and the pitch he swings
in ropes went into right center field
this ball is headed onto the warning
trap
they give the hold sign to mount castle
as stewart claps his hands he's at
second base with a double
and the orioles with the tying run at
third and the go ahead run it second and
now michael franco
will step to the plate
and see if he can end this orioles
drought with runners in scoring position
a little life at camden yards with a
count one and one three two red sox
set in pitch
franco hits it on the ground to first
dull beck coming to the plate throw is
off line and mount castle slides in
safely we're tied up at three
freddie galvez is awaiting his first big
moment with the orioles at the plate
will it come here in the bottom of the
eighth some would say he's do others
would say he's overdue
he deals and there's a swing and a line
drive in the left it's down for a base
hit mckenna comes down and scores
there's your first big moment at the
plate from freddie galvez an rbi single
in the left the hitless drought over the
tie over the orioles lead it 4-3 in the
bottom of the eight
strike for a series win tomorrow and
valdez will see if he can close it out
base hit into right field
hard hit for a single gonzalez with his
second knock tonight and the red sox
have something brewing and francie with
terrific power
will he get some to drive
live shot base hit into right
gonzalez rounding second on his way into
third he slides in safely the red sox
have runners in first and third and one
away one down red sox trying to get
gonzalez in from third to tie it
[Applause]
hot shot sliding stab galvez got the out
there on to first not in time
not in time gonzales scores
and the red sox have tied it up so
another extra in a game and tied up 4-4
and dylan tate will be the new hurler
for the orioles gordugo tonight quiet 0
for 4. you can get noisy right here
though field is in runner at 3rd and
chavez
oh that's going to be off the mit to the
backstop the run is in and the red sox
have the lead 5-4
and the 2-0 from the left-hander
base hit into left field radugo on the
run rounding third here's the throw it's
going to be cut and another run is in
and a big run at that the red sox on top
six to four in the 10.
swag and a miss he struck him out the
red sox win again and that is five in a
row